[Music]
all right so who's one female rapper
that you guys know of that is only
relevant because of her crazy drama
Missy Elliott oh I was actually just
only female rapper that I know yeah you
talking about Azealia Banks you would
know she's a rapper
yeah rapper she was just some like
publicity ho rapper her music is alright
okay Minaj gets into it but I think
she's actually really good - she's not
known for her publicity end of like
fighting - so alright well what's going
down in the rap hip-hop world you know
as they advance could could really pop
off as like she has a cool voice she
could she could really blow up if she
didn't get wrapped up in drama so much
she loves drop she would be good if she
she would be a better rapper if she
didn't get wrapped up in drama nice do
you think you should be a rapper bars I
don't even know was ill Eubanks is just
stop yeah like three million news on
your channel I'm a Boomer yep give it up
you guys got a pool put in so she she
went off on her Instagram story talking
about Nikki talking about doja cat
talking about [ __ ] Adrian grandi no
green baby i got a pool guy if you guys
are interested Beck from Entourage
anyway so she ends up talking about she
get fav Chappelle oh you guys haven't
heard about this no this is interesting
alright so I'm gonna play like I'm gonna
play the part of her Instagram story
where she's talking about oh no not Dave
ready
don't be attacking Dave here we go this
is this is this is what actually
[ __ ] a lot of [ __ ] very powerful
[ __ ] men and you will [ __ ] gag if
I spill all the [ __ ] tea and ruin all
the [ __ ] marriages that's a lot of
tea that I'll be wanting to spit on your
black [ __ ] especially like when you'll
be seeing me get it's getting attacked
in the media [ __ ] you gotta come to my
rescue ship how I should move on your
[ __ ] marriage your [ __ ] marriage I
should tell the [ __ ] world that we
fought those [ __ ]
I should solve all [ __ ] world of [ __ ]
well to me so what the [ __ ] I'm keeping
secrets the gun [ __ ] for your purple
Wow oh and that makes imagine that was
like yes maybe give me that [ __ ]
legend energy I'm slash tough [ __ ] right
up so this is obviously not at all
horrible for Dave Chappelle oh yeah [ __ ]
me so good you can [ __ ] me any time I'm
just excited for the next special
literally everyone like what is he gonna
say about the rumors real we don't know
knows nowadays bro but you know the
funny [ __ ] was when when Dave Chappelle
was trending because of this on Twitter
I looked up Dave Chappelle just see what
people are saying and one of the tweets
that made me laugh is someone was like
oh it's not Dave Chappelle trending and
I was like oh my god I got so concerned
that he got he got the rona or you know
and something happened thank God it's
just a little cheating well one of the
Appel skits where he talked about having
that love contract and that he had like
every woman signed before he ever [ __ ]
them like just in case cause he's a
celebrity in check they brought up that
like screenshot of the love contract
they're like come on man this guy keeps
a track
sucks like she's clearly lying oh and
then this other one where it was like a
jiff when he's in the club and he goes
like this to one of the girls yeah like
come on like everyone thinks is thinking
they're actually dragging as Elia banks
instead of amazing so they're saying
that she lied just for publicity I mean
that's what people are saying yeah like
just I mean it kind of seems like it
though because the whole while the
night's Wilin out situation was like
wasn't she fibbin she was exaggerating
for sure yeah yeah she was uh
recollecting some things I got worried
she just sucked his dick or maybe they
didn't even do that maybe she was trying
really hard and because she's high as
[ __ ] she's like [ __ ] you then I'm gonna
drag your ass cuz you don't wanna [ __ ]
me well me personally I hashtag believe
all women and so no matter what she says
I believe it that's right why are you
guys blaming the victim here yep yeah
she could say she [ __ ] me and I'd be
that apologize I think if it was an
Asian girl I'd believe it well that's
funny because that's another thing that
was that was getting tweeted why is it
no because here's why possibility me has
a asian fetish yeah so like what what
are they that's the joke yeah one of the
tweets was like they saw as alias video
and they're like oh Dave Chappelle has
sex with black women Oh white guy
blinking gif Jim Halpert from the office
really yeah they were just like you're
just trying to stir up [ __ ] anywhere
that's what's tricky is when you
somebody who has got in trouble for so
much drama right even not necessarily
lying but when you're when you when you
get trending for so much drama all the
time like even when you say some [ __ ]
that's true people are gonna be like
Steven Seagal hit me it's like so I
don't believe you why did she just
believe it because she's a woman oh
there you go I mean yeah me too yeah why
did you choose Dave oh because he's a
legend egg I mean I feel like based off
what she's saying she's sucked a bunch
of legendary dick Gary black man is he's
the most legendary right now
well it just sounded like she was really
salty that made like if this is true
that they have [ __ ] her they don't
right exactly they don't take care of
her when then people are responding to
that like do you expect a like
successful married man to come to your
rescue what no from what from what I
understood is she was ranting because I
think it was like during during the doja
cat controversies right a lot of people
were coming to her defense and then but
she was like how come all these black
celebrities don't defend black artists
like black fimo artists and he's like
all and she was saying all the times
agate rags none of these folks all of it
all the time but she was complaining
that no one ever comes to her defense
but it's like bro they were defending
don't you get or what was that drunk I
didn't even read into that
there's a buzz it was a whole bunch it
was the cat drama she got cancelled like
three times last week no joke yeah yeah
yeah she got cancelled came back on
cancer came back they got they got the
cancel button and repeatedly clicked the
mouse on it yeah she got canceled a
bunch of sounds because like that she it
was a lot of things Wow Wow
yeah that's one tweet that went viral
that said something along the lines of
like dojaquez father is black and he
left her and like you expect her to grow
up loving black men or something like
that it was a lot of [ __ ] it was last
year it was it was one thing they're mad
because like one thing there was like
videos of her do y'all remember this
website called tinychat
oh yeah so it was videos of her in tiny
childhood like it's basically like
almost like it's like a public zoom
everybody's just in there saying a bunch
of [ __ ] right and I guess they were
saying that she was in a tiny chat room
where like racist dudes were prominent
and like making racial jokes and she was
like laughing at it that was one of
things people were saying and they had
been recorded that and there was like
record anymore yeah and then there was
like some [ __ ] where she was complaining
about the texture of her hair and she
was saying like I hate 4c hair horseys
like the most like the kinkiest of like
the textures and she was like I hate
there cuz she was saying how difficult
it was and they were saying like she's
like a self-hating
black woman cuz she doesn't like you
know she's like saying that hair is like
annoying or whatever and then it was
like what else man it was a bunch of
[ __ ]
oh and she made a song called didn't do
nothing I and that I had never heard the
term personally but they were saying
that is a term used by liked by racists
when when when when black people get
accused of a crime they say oh they're
like oh I didn't do nothing so it's like
it's like a derogatory term so she made
a song called that and they were saying
and she was and she did a whole ID live
apology like breaking it all down saying
look man I was trying to take the word
and like flip it oh yeah she's like I
wanna take that phrase and flip it and
you know kind of take power over it but
people like weren't really filling that
answer and then it was just a whole
bunch of [ __ ] Wow
well I had never heard of didn't do
nothing until that whole controversy and
then I kind of like looking into it and
then um and then she kind of broke it
all down in her eyes you laugh she's
like look man I wasn't saying this hair
isn't attractive or it's not like good
she's just like personally I just have a
really hard time dealing with my natural
hair and I was being vocal and
complaining about it maybe I sense yes
you ever say I wish I had three see her
no no she's like the 4c I mean it's a
look good honor
I don't even know what she looks like no
you don't know she said your coin looks
like that's about it I love those a cat
man she has a big ol natural ass to like
it's so nice big natural how do you know
when it's natural by the way moves and
her thigh ratio she's very thick thighs
Kardashian ass is so bad it's a shelf
hanging off that's big but her but have
you seen her thighs whose thighs Kim
Kardashian's thighs this is funny
[Music]
look if Kanye likes it Kim likes it too
and if Kim's like you know what I take a
chair with me wherever I go
hashtag women are always right that's
right I believe him I believe her yeah
oh yeah hey babe
what the [ __ ] Dave Chappelle my dude I
have I hate her now cool that Dave
Chappelle so legendary seems like he's
bulletproof he doesn't even have to save
the shots fired were like all
compliments yeah mazie yeah let you [ __ ]
me again it's way too big it's it's a
legends dick it was so good when he
dresses it's gonna be so great no I
can't wait I know
so in case you guys didn't know he has
been married to his wife for the last 15
years and he has like couple kids yeah
have you seen his kids they just look
just like him put a scintilla penal
versions of them really yeah what what
Asian are the kids you know okay yeah
what are you not Corona
it seems your elbow oh why would I be
sitting you're sure yeah they have three
kids together
I always wondering like I wonder how
those kids are growing up cuz I don't
know anything about his wife I just
don't like what his persona is and I'm
just like I wonder if he's always
cracking jokes when is comedy set he was
saying that his kid is a big fan of
Kevin Hart he doesn't think his dad's
funny at all like when they talks about
they go to the kennel heart concert they
can fight it backstage yeah and it's
eating all the food like he's never
eaten before they felt all embarrassed I
just I wish like in a parallel universe
you know we can get a glimpse of what
the Chappelle show would be like today
like I wonder what kind of jokes even
crack especially with how everyone is
like super sensitive yeah
[Music]
[Music]
you